hoje pudesse começar no fim o lado
pessoal do que ele falou eu dar que seja
muito bem vindo se imaginam br ou o
estudo é a introdução sabe evitar é bom
hoje estamos aqui para jogar faz na eds
e manter o foco em fred espera pior file
a este que noel foto 1 não digam que eu
provei o jogo apronto eu acho que
fundara que em equipe porque ontem
contrabando um boy eo preenchimento
agora consigo escolhê lo eu não sei com
um mês como escolhe os nativos visto que
não ok eu preciso tirar uma personagem
provocavam boy
eu vou tirar o fred por conferir acho
que não faz assim tanto dano e vamos lá
ver como é que isto ocorre agora
chegamos no nosso mundinho fugido
vicioso ok eu já tinha falado com isso
zé manel aqui mas vamos lá ver o que é
que eu tava vendo agora eu tenho 48 anos
por isso com isso consigo comprar nada
esta bocha damas tensão meu mais para
até 250 também pensar que vem droga
vamos buscar eu tenho de ganhar aquela
pérola né espero agora eu acho que
mendonça que também vendia coisas
exatamente uma venda que já que ela vai
nos fazem esses problemas e acho que vou
comprar aqui e sistema nervoso pronto
comprar e eu posso que paulo aqui não é
isso nós já tá bom eu não estou
encontrando nada só borboletas que é
isto um governo fred e vamos tentar
atacar o pessoal vai lá eu acho que
encontrei uma pista para conquistar
passado o look em alberta menéres a
trilha avaí não quer saber vai porque
estava em uma área para piscar o que é o
que vamos tendo escutec dos faxinais o
fred indo tomar drogas
alguém só vocês conseguem tocar um funk
animatrônico em zuma que aquilo é um
labirinto o shopping espera já possui
também que pelo esquerdo agora está em
drogas pra mim e isto é droga cara tem
que ganhar essa coisa não sair é suposto
fazer o quê que falou vamos ter lá
transportados para uma floresta com
árvores cortadas ópera a itália o
tesouro eu quero que o tesouro mas temos
porque ela perde a primeira mãe costuma
subir
ok ok vamos saber qual é o poder do
bumbum é agora após usar o do luís mas
não é minha praia da azurara atacar
ajudar embora btow3 machado pai
agora vamos tirar minha esquerda o
zagueiro shopping aeb fax com seus
papéis passaram nível a notícia
o tom e por sua falta de chica a anepe
cuca vai da creche meu deus este é um
dado que os vossos que é muito forte e
por isso nós vamos continuar aqui uma
instituição o qualifier para o bolton
querem que lá vamos nós outra vez os
volantes fazem tudo por acaso o cai
agora vamos fazer o que a pé nós
precisamos de vida de genebra e chicago
é preciso colocar a faixa pra da vida ou
não aos 40 quase morri gelei cayambe
chan chan já não sei o que fazer não
quero é que esquenta
ok o tiro atravessou mais que entra meu
matemática por favor a sérvia júnior eu
estou fazendo muito da minha mãe no
morro ai ai não chega morreu
nené a conseguir matar um bosta inteiro
de usar a outra equipa o que já é muito
bom e isso quer dizer que nós já temos
de incluir aqui eu quero é que o
profissional mas não consegui que tem
uma pedra que a frente outra vez usa da
árvore o que vamos lá estou aqui é fácil
matar é só uma série de humor já morreu
pronto foi fácil e música pura e eu não
consigo entrar nestes casos a agenda eu
acho que nunca vi por aqui me fico no
feminino o que é que o meu deus que é
estupro nem quer saber o que é que ele
simplesmente ataquem ataque e davi de
chica é mais raro é preciso 0 e viram
aqui o dano para nós estamos confusos e
agora não pode ser falta um foco de
ataque conseguimos com queijo nível
estava em uma caverna eles tinham já que
ela não quer apanhar essas coisas porque
parecem por aí é dinheiro
achamos parar o ataque o maior falta de
um chip ex taxista terá um chip possível
chips agora eu consegui parar agora este
pico da força é isso não vai ajudar para
caraças já olhou tesouro aqui
sim esse é meu uma tac um morreu em
termos muito fortes eu devia conseguir a
sério mais pesado não vamos nem quero
fugir fujam amigos fugir e não conseguiu
fugir
rogge que eu vou ter que matar os
fantasmas eles não deixam sujeira plata
morreu eu tinha onde aí o que o fox e
esse né não pode ser mesmo que só
aparecem bosque não é justo eu só quero
uma chave precisa que eu não quero lutar
contra ninguém
a e chica morreu a série homem acho que
nasci para morrer é sempre vai morrer
agora tá com uma chance a ninguém
busquei opel ainda enfrenta um chique e
oferta em um fox e brutal até eu vou
tocar aqui alguma coisa não sei se foi a
temática da vida mas vou tocar é chique
pela frente um chique e vou trocar
talvez o fox inep pelo feto foxy é isso
e porque a porta desta casa é tipo a pdg
nela eu acho que é porque nós temos que
passar mesmo assim o caminho que provar
a aérea por aqui sim
olha aqui outra postagem é não é é o
final entre descobrir um carro novo é
esse mesmo ok a ayahuasca designers vai
falar se vai vai e toxic de alguma coisa
não sei não sei que é um fusível eu tô
atacar a tua está fazendo ano e
conseguimos muito fácil muito fácil a
revolta de que a floresta o sport também
texto já é uma área nova e vamos lá ver
o que eu consigo fazer aí mais uma
ratazana a sério é só uma vaga é fácil
matado o pai rony tóxico mt alunos
meu deus esta é uma causa da forte ela
era só uma mas que existem várias coisas
o que é estar janeiro
hogan
a música passa de uma música fleishman
música toda é e pessoal
o curso que eu descobri uma pedra de
toque para o pedido agora neve não sabem
como fazer mas o calor continua a
agravar este bom é isso com uma faca e
furto fim vai até a próxima